welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the biggest change in zack
snyder's justice league at least when it
comes to the broader implications of the
dc cinematic universe
was the flash and his newly revealed
ability to reverse time not only did
this close the loop with the unanswered
questions from snyder's batman v
superman the precise ripple effects we
saw of barry allen's timeline
manipulation
established some solid rules for the dc
in titles like the upcoming flash movie
which is confirmed to adapt the crucial
flashpoint paradox comic storyline as
well as other titles like the suicide
squad and the batman
if those films choose to do so and
that's a big if
at the moment the canonicity of the
snyder cut is according to snyder
somewhere between whatever the studio
decides to do with their ip
and whatever the most passionate fans
want it to be arguably that's always
been the case but here i gotta explain
how exactly the flash and the snyder cut
altered the timeline of the dc
universe and everything we have learned
about this upcoming flash film
and how we should look at titles like
the suicide squad and the batman
in relation to the snyder cut and the
flash okay so zack snyder's changes to
barry allen's story in justice league
began with his dramatic rescue of iris
west followed by new dialogue with his
father henry allen
i can't sit here and watch you running
place in central city for some old dude
who's not going anywhere
i want you to make your own future if
you're living in the past
henry is falsely in prison for the
murder of barry's mother nora an
unsolved case inspiring barry's pursuit
of a criminal justice degree to clear
henry's name now later in the snyder cut
right before barry uses his speed force
to jumpstart the mother box to resurrect
superman he
explains this in another new line added
by snyder i don't like to break this
rule but when i approach the speed of
light i
look crazy things happen to time but and
so that when barry reverses time to sync
with the motherbox's point of contact
that action alters the timeline causing
this echo
in cyborg's brain to see how
resurrecting superman leads to a
different dark fate and then in the
final battle barry misses his window to
blast cyborg into the mother boxes
fulfilling that destiny cyborg foresaw
so barry reverses time again to fix this
just gotta go faster than the speed of
light far beyond the speed of light
gotta break the rule barry and you've
gotta do it now
make your own future
that's all right
but despite barry's fix his reversal
still leaves elements of cyborg's
foreseen future in place
superman and the rest of the planet may
not have been scorched but as the
epilogue scene shows
we still have a future in which wonder
woman and aquaman die
in which the joker had killed lois and
turned superman against the rest of the
justice league in which darkseid
conquers earth with his armada
all of that still remains the future at
least for now henry allen's earlier
lined about running in
place was likely a nod to the cosmic
treadmill
which in the 2011 flashpoint comic that
is inspiring the 2022 flash film barry
allen uses this cosmic treadmill to
build up a speed force and travel to a
specific point in time
in order to prevent the murder of his
mother nora but like the best time
travel stories things get
wonderfully effed up nora allen's murder
was spoiler warning
actually committed by a figure called
reverse flash one of those
it happened because it will have
happened predestined type 4 time travel
stories and barry's attempt to fix this
timeline leads to him spending a lot of
time in an
alternate flashpoint universe a darkest
timeline where
bruce wayne was the one who was killed
and then the batman of this world is his
grieving father the cold-blooded thomas
wayne the whole planet is wrecked by
a war between the atlanteans and the
amazonians that flooded most of europe
it ends in the sweetest cross-multiverse
connection between thomas wayne and his
son
and the flash restoring all of these
alternate broken timelines into
one universe of 52 vocal characters
which dc comics called the new 52. now
the snyder cut actually pointed to these
possible events in other ways in the
film
like when diana and arthur alluded to
the history of their peoples hating each
other
and steppenwolf mentioning the existence
of a multiverse
the anti-life equation the key to
controlling
all life and all will throughout the
multiverse
and zack snyder himself confirmed during
a watch-a-long q a
that barry's time reversal was meant to
evolve
into time travel and before all this
when snyder was asked about the flash's
cameo in batman v superman snyder
revealed that his
intention was to have barry's cosmic
treadmill
down in the bat cave actually in that
spot where in the snyder cut bruce told
diana that he was visited by barry
this would all explain why bruce had
that echo of the future back in batman v
superman
like cyborg in the snyder cut barry
altering the timeline in that moment
caused bruce to experience a
vision of the future timeline as it was
being rewritten
and now the implication of this epilogue
scene of the snyder cut with joker was
that batman and the flash were looking
for a way to change
joker's mind in the past to stop him
from killing lois
and maybe now with harley quinn they
finally have the joker's key
so this was probably snyder's plan for
how time travel is gonna work in a
justice league part two and three but
will the flash movie of 2022 use any of
this
but before we continue if you've been
avoiding checking the balance on that
credit card because you're afraid of how
bad it might be
upstart can help you face it and finally
pay it off
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment upstart
finds smarter rates with trusted
partners because they assess
more than just a credit score with a
five minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans from 1
000 to 50
000 loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application
you can get approved the same day and
receive funds as fast as
one business day if debt is taking over
your life it's time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
new rockstars that's upstart.com new
rockstars don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you go to
upstart.com
new rockstars i mean zack snyder did say
last week in an interview with kyle
mcmahon that it's not really up to him
if the snyder verse continues in his
vision exactly
warner says you know in dc films
by all means they're in charge of their
own world and that's what they do
to them the theatrical cut of justice
league is canon
that's what they kind of jump off of and
you know so
um my little micro universe is its own
thing
and i'm pretty happy with that i mean i
you know i'll let the um let the fans
decide how they want to
how they want to go forward what we know
of the flash film is that it is going to
center around barry's quest to save his
mother and clear his father's name henry
allen billy crudup is actually going to
be recast with ron livingston due to
billy creative schedule conflicts
nora allen's going to be played by
maribel verdu kirsty clements is
confirmed to return as iris west
and ben affleck is returning as bruce
wayne the creators of this film have
confirmed that we are looking at a truly
multiversal plot that skews into
alternate dc timelines we actually
started to see this with ezra miller's
cameo in last year's cw crisis on
infinite earth's crossover event a
separate franchise now established as an
alternate timeline within the dceu
time stream michael keaton was also
announced to return as batman in a
mentor role to barry allen
though recently when keaton was asked
about this he was like i don't know what
that film's all about either way warner
brothers did release concept art of a
tim burton era batman fighting alongside
flash in addition to this sasha kaye was
confirmed as super girl in this film and
there's been speculation at least that
danny devito might show up as the
penguin or jeffrey dean morgan could
return as the dceu thomas wayne
so if the snyder cut is set in its own
microverse
to use schneider's words separate from
the rest of the dceu
with its sacred continuity of aquaman
and wonder woman 1984
all that doesn't matter if the flash
could use the multiverse to make the cw
continuity and the tim burton era batman
cannon logically the snyder cut could
just be another
else world that the flash pulls other
batman from snyder even gave them an
easy layup by
including among the ruins of the hall of
justice in cyborg's vision of that
altered timeline
a portrait of thomas wayne jeffrey dean
morgan
now this could also explain any
continuity questions you might have
about james gunn's suicide squad gunn
has said his movie is its own thing
not a direct sequel to the 2016 film and
it has a star oh that's very different
from the mechanized starro that we saw
in the snyder cut the harley quinn of
this movie
is a bit different you could argue that
she's evolved from her character in the
past or that she's just like a different
character who doesn't at all care where
she came from
like that property of the joker tattoo
changed to property of no one
references of her vigilantism maybe in
birds of prey and now she's got this new
hatred of personalized license plates
maybe not
mr j in 2016 suicide squad but really i
think the broader goal
of the flash film will be to retcon all
of this inconsistent continuity as just
various different
else worlds that are still left
independent of each other with the
freedom to continue forward in whatever
way they want and that includes a new
elseworld continuity for the upcoming
matt reeves robert pattinson batman
a kind of new 52 reset but for the films
one that doesn't erase anything that
came before but just celebrates all of
it and moves forward support this
channel by checking out one of our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerge.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstars and subscribing to
rockstars here on youtube for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you